These students at the University of Toronto
are angry
because a so-called
men's rights activist was speaking
at their college.
His words are hate speech, they said.
No hate speech on campus!
They stopped people like this man
from getting in to see the lecture.
The boy crisis.
The so-called men's rights advocate
speaking inside was Warren Farrell.
For the first time in US history,
boys will have less education than their dads.
Farrell is an odd person to call anti-woman.
He was actually an early feminist movement leader.
Here he is with Gloria Steinem.
But as he learned more,
he started to disagree with parts of modern feminism.
I don't agree with the part of feminism
that says men are the oppressors
and women are the oppressed.
That part of feminism is sick.
Men are running the government,
they run most companies,
they make more money.
Our dads and our grandpas, they made sacrifices
to make more money and then the feminist movement
turned all of that sacrifice on the part of men
against men
and they haven't said you were discriminated against
men in your own way,
you were obliged to earn more money
or we wouldn't even be thinking about marrying you.
We wouldn't be thinking about having
children with you.
In his book The Boy Crisis,
Farrell notes that both sexes struggle.
Today, boys are almost 1/3 less likely
to get college degrees than girls,
twice as likely to commit suicide.
Why is no one talking about this?
Because we have believed for the last 50 years
that men had all the privilege and men had all the power.
Men and boys started falling behind
when government began
subsidizing single mothers.
They tear the family apart
by giving money to mothers
when fathers are absent
and not giving money to mothers
when fathers are present.
That policy,
part of the welfare system created in the 60's
helped lead to more households without fathers.
Farrell says that hurts boys most.
Why are boys more affected than girls?
Boys tend to not have as many skills
at developing friendships
and developing emotional connections
and so when the family connection breaks apart,
it affects them more profoundly
than it does their sisters.
This 1989 CBS interview
captured the changing attitudes
after welfare programs started.
I think I can make it as a single parent.
But don't you think you might need help
in raising that baby, from a man?
Not really.
It doesn't make any difference
whether she needs a man, it makes a difference that
her children need a father.
What happens when the kids don't have fathers?
Children do worse in 70 different areas.
They're far more likely to be disobedient,
delinquent, drop out of school.
Fathers are critical, says Farrell
because men tend to parent differently.
For example, men roughhouse more with kids.
Why is that important?
Roughhousing creates so many skill sets.
The father's creating a bond with the child,
so the children don't mind the discipline
because the discipline is the price they pay
for more fun with dad.
People think that mothers tend to be better parents
because on average,
they're more attentive to children's needs.
Mothers are more empathetic as a rule to the children
than dads, but an empathetic
parent does not create an empathetic child.
An empathetic parent is someone
who's always thinking of the children's needs,
which teach the children to always
have his or her needs thought of.
The empathy is created by the father or the mother,
requiring the child to think about the father's needs,
the mother's needs,
their brother's needs.
In fact, he says helping children too much is harmful.
Dr. Phil covered that in this video clip.
Moms are filled with love
and they want to make sure their children do well,
so they often do for the children.
Dads are filled with love but the way
that dads love
is to feel that I need to love the children
by having the children
learn how to do for themselves.
Having both an involved mother and father leads
to the best outcome for kids.
A government summary of studies
notes children who live with their fathers
are more likely to have good physical and
emotional health, to achieve academically,
to avoid drugs, violence, and delinquent behavior.
We need men to be involved in the fathering role
to a much greater degree
than they are and have been.
Even when we control for the amount of money
a father and mother earn,
children with dads still do much better.